Whindersson Por que que você não faz
vídeo novo é porque eu não aguento ficar
falando das mesmas coisas direto
carnaval ela sabe o que acontece as
mesmas coisas aí eu vou lá gravar e
posta aí você de novo filha da mãe mas
agora aconteceu uma coisa nova no
planeta inteiro um assunto do planeta se
a vida inteligente inteligente para vir
até aqui observar mas burro para
escolher um lugar porque Escolhe os
Estados Unidos dá tempo você falar ai
[__] derruba
deu tempo não Discovery channe gravar
sua música Planeta x-97 viemos hein
então uma mensagem aqui para caso algum
Alienígena esteja observando Brasil
mesmo Brasil o negócio é Brasil aqui nós
fala de tudo qualquer coisa brasileiro
tem muita sorte é porque se os
alienígenas souber que aqui no Brasil um
monte de 12 invadiu o Congresso Nacional
Não vamos deixar Os Comunistas
transformar em nossos fios em LGBT cabe
nas vezes